[Music]
in not today Satan News submitted by
diarrhoea suits
Easter's was a long time do you not
realize that you have diarrhea since
Easter why can't we just have like a
salad or something the Vatican is out
training more exorcists after increased
reports of demonic possession Wow
sir statistics show that during 2017
South America has been dealing with more
demons than usual 27 percent more than
2015 Philippines have been dealing with
50 percent more demons in danger oh my
god this is an epidemic what are we
gonna do
Catholic countries yeah you know how
they have like a world like the Vatican
is like the hub right and then that's
where like the the dr. evil lives and
then like everybody this Pope seems
pretty mean I was thinking uh I was
thinking of The Da Vinci Code the bad
guy mm yeah the guy that whips himself
Shh she died oh uh
so apparently exorcism has tripled in
recent years with 500,000 alleged cases
all North Italy
annually come on out a possibly got a
[ __ ] demon epidemic what's going oh
they must love pasta too that's why
they're there yes the Sicilian priests
and trained Exorcist named Benito Paula
so he said that he attributed the rise
to the popularity of fortune tellers and
tarot cards which he said opened the
door to the to the evil and took
possession that's popular girl I thought
that phase like has gone impasse already
that makes sense men the more crystal
balls in the area the more spirits are
attracted to it I mean
believing that Ouija board chicks I
played with that show when I was like
eight and I'm doing pretty okay ever
really oh really yeah huh
it started off as a toy I wonder how
that started like you have it that that
that's the stigma because of a toy these
things start okay like it all about
human perception and intent so I could
make this the devil's flute how is if
enough people agree in if enough people
give it that fear and value that's what
it becomes
so it's human intent that creates it
that's like cults yeah yeah but it's
like it does nothing to me I just
imagine it comes from the ancient times
of the Hasbro people it'll do nothing
have you guys ever seen the movie a
skeleton key I think I know is that the
one where they possess they take over
the bodies okay what's her name the
actress Kate Hudson anyway so her
character in that movie they keep
telling her like you know you you don't
have to worry about voodoo if you don't
believe in it but if you believe in it
then that's when they'll get you in like
that's when it won't back to you you
thought if she didn't care about it the
whole movie yeah and so they throw out
the whole time she's just kept saying I
don't believe I don't believe I don't
believe when she ends up getting
possessed because she did believe
because she's scared
that's my thing with the whole like
Ouija board and like I'm like I am
scared because I it's hard for me not to
a Mexican household like every single
one of your Thea's and fields has had
some encounter with the [ __ ] ghost of
some sort and then in their little town
to that town for sure that El Diablo has
like been there and they know because
the footprints on the [ __ ] dirt
there's only that one house that has a
demon peeking out the window or some
always so growing up like that you're
kind of already pre like you're
conditioned to be afraid of like ghosts
no no we had a kid like I was always
like there's demons and I would love to
meet a demon and I would go and like all
these haunted places Queen Mary please I
do believe I want to believe I wanted to
[ __ ] come and I possessed me and do
all that [ __ ]
you're like a self conscious girl at the
club how come no guys I hate now
like I want to see that [ __ ] hang I
want to see though I live with you I
don't want to see that I want to you you
grew up with I want to grow up with
[ __ ] doors opening closing in a house
all you gotta do is make a [ __ ] across
with two things I was taught as long as
you say the name of Jesus Christ then
the devil goes you know we were taught
we were taught if you see a ghost you
have to cuss out loud and it goes away
that's what happens you invite the ghost
if you cus they want negative energy
that's you know I heard that one say
Jesus cries and SS carry a [ __ ]
melody means will save you say that
animal I eat a [ __ ] the only tofu
[ __ ] whatever then the ghost
Buddhists know so it's the same [ __ ]
it's easy we went camping the other day
while we were we were at the cabin and
we were telling ghost stories and I
started giving getting those shivers
bound up like down my spine and that's
how I know there's like ghosts you know
or I just get scared ya ever get those
like it goes from the [ __ ] spine and
it goes down to your butt and you're
like oh like a duck that's [ __ ]
shaking there you don't feel it you
don't feel it when I had my side shave I
felt it oh no I feel that [ __ ] it goes
shake my ass and [ __ ] ghosts love buzz
cuts I like going on ecstasy and then
you put the vapor rub down your back and
someone blows on it
the go see you experienced in it I never
had it's expensive pressure when you're
15 years old I never did the inhaler so
people have been healers with this [ __ ]
you did you have both held shits of my
nose I said Oh what is that race of
course woman I can do it at Ray's well
it's dancing but before you have
ugly-ass face damn that's a his face I
haven't heard that in a while face face
I mean vising it was a 40 reference face
you make when you smell something smells
like piss yeah but you're when you're at
con rolling we're anyways if we're
getting an air B&B next time I think we
should bring some insects some save or
don't say that I'm trying to clear out
the demons holy water the priests boring
yeah cuz I don't know who died up in
that [ __ ] I'm trying to have a
good vacation you know Oh remember when
we did the writers every time I went up
there I was like reaching out like oh
[ __ ] and there's that [ __ ] pirate
dude that's hanging out on the every
time I'm looking out there's just like
[ __ ] feet hanging there like oh [ __ ]
that the [ __ ] eggs back inside and it
was windy cuz it was the beach why
didn't you sleep my birth bed could his
parts good because what better than the
pirate feet I like my bed dude when I
was in I when I was in Japan I crashed
at my friend's place he got a house out
there because like he wanted to be more
in like the the more like foresty
country area because he wants to be away
from the city
my cousin it was [ __ ] creepy like I
was sharing the living room with my
friends and at night I learned was like
this was steps upstairs I was like what
the [ __ ] i couldnt sleep the whole night
like i did not sleep i hate on their
covers that i just waited so that's a
[ __ ] ghost not yeah okay no it's see
like old japan that [ __ ] was haunted as
[ __ ] dude and then the light is only
like one light in the middle the room
that pools like just a light bulb the
string it was [ __ ] terrible i can't
sleep
into it you know what i always tell
self about spirits I'd be like just wait
you [ __ ] like when I'm in your
dimension I'm gonna give you [ __ ]
hell but how do you know who it is
yeah remember them my spirit is but when
I die my soul is gonna be like oh I
remember you [ __ ] bully [ __ ] one I
[ __ ] I got two of my eyes mother oh
you're gonna be like arias from Game of
Thrones you're gonna have like your
killers oh my have a demon list right
when I'm about to be on my deathbed I'm
gonna live the good life that
[ __ ] demon that haunted me in
Okinawa [ __ ] you I'm coming for you
[ __ ]
goodbye what would you do if you're like
a ghost and you're trying to hump the
[ __ ] out of someone and then it's Joe
and then he's like oh yeah you read my
brain you know how like in the movies
it's always like some girl that's all
[ __ ] up and then like she's all like
right and I'm always old oh yeah and I'm
like you can't even tell the cops [ __ ]
you came into my house you ain't even
real that took a really twisted like
what it's like you're what the ghost
comes you just do some weird okay well
what if you do the word [ __ ] and then
the ghost is like oh yeah
then I made a new friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]